You edge the poolside, chlorine-stenched air
filling your nose, the sounds of splashing
and lifeguards whistling bouncing off the
indoor pool facility walls.
The water ripples, family and friends egging
you to cannonball in, the pool almost beckoning
you to jump with its suggestive waves.
Yet there remains an underlying fear, one
that brings your hands to your face and causes
your teeth to chatter, even as the pool, clear
as glass with chlorine, hides no secrets.
A monster, some teeth-gnashing megalodon ascending
from the depths of extinction; leviathan curling
its barbed tail to strike its prey at any
moment; or even some vast, unknowable force,
ancient as Earth, hardly comprehensible to
human minds, waiting, dreaming to breach the
surface.
No matter what form this gargantuan, invisible
monster takes, you know one thing: once you
jump in, you will not return to shore.
You take a moment, recompose yourself, and
laugh off the fear.
Maybe a product of too much research on the
Bloop, that deep-ocean sound continuing to
confound scientists as to its cause, or maybe
too much binging Infographics videos on sea
monsters, krakens and Loch Ness Monsters,
mysterious globsters cast onto shores throughout
America.
Whatever the origin, the thought seems ridiculous
to you now, and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimeter escape
your mind as you hurl yourself into the water.
SCP-1128
In the vast archives of a hidden site, stuffed
into a drawer amongst uncountable horrors
like it, the SCP Foundation holds a description
of a vast, unfathomable horror, that'll make
you more suspicious the next time you pass
a pool, lake, or even a bathtub or puddle
of water.
SCP-1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster, lurking
in waters unknown, and that's all the Foundation
will let anyone not assigned to testing know
about it.
While the Foundation has never shied away
from those Moby Dicks of the deep, including
the several-thousand kilometer-long arthropod
SCP-169, and has even utilized such predators
in the past for their own benefit, like the
lengthy beast SCP-3000, SCP-1128 poses a unique
challenge: anyone who knows of its description
beyond surface-level details will fall under
the anomaly's effect.
The representation you see now is merely an
artist's interpretation of the basic prompt.
The Foundation, of course, had to discover
the monster's effects in the first place.
The chain of communication becomes foggy,
but a tip from an unknown source alerted the
Foundation to the monster's existence, and
details regarding its manifestation.
One man, who had stumbled upon the entity's
full description, started developing acute
thalassophobia, the fear of large bodies of
water.
Not bodies in the water, mind you.
The man refused to relax on the beach or fly
overseas, claiming he could see the monster's
dark silhouette lurking underwater, ever scouting
for him.
This eventually extended to even closed bodies
of water, like lakes, ponds, and pools, still
insisting that the creature swam under the
surface, trailing him wherever he went.
His friends dismissed him as crazy, and he
too believed he had fallen under some hysteria.
He decided to take a nice, warm bath to soothe
his mind and ease his troubles.
He turned on the faucet, and let the tub fill
up.
He put on his best bathing suit ready to calm
his anxiety once and for all.
This had been plaguing his mind for far too
long and he was ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia.
Basically he was sick and tired of being sick
and tired over the idea of it all.
He mustered up the courage and with the anticipation
to just simply relax, he took his first confident
step into the tub.
He paused for a moment and breathed a sigh
of relief.
He picked up his other foot and stepped fully
into the bath.
SPLASH!
He fell straight down right through the tub.
Waves and bubbles blocked his vision, his
arms flailed as he sunk deeper into an abyss
of water and fear.
This wasn’t supposed to happen, he thought.
Several moments later, while still in a full
on panic, the buoyancy of his body began to
slow his sinking.The bubbles from his underwater
screams rose above him, and he began to follow
their direction, scrambling back up to where
he'd come.
Just as he made it back to the surface of
the tub water - choking and hyper-ventilating
in terror - he swore he could see a distant
creature, the very same that stalked him through
oceans and pools, staring at him.
Shaking, he hoisted himself out of the water,
and ran out of the house.
Hysterical, he ran through the surrounding
neighborhood, desperately searching for someone
he could relay his experience to.
Blinded by fear, he neglected to spot a puddle
in the middle of the road he ran on.
He raised his foot, arched forward, and landed
straight into the seemingly shallow water.
SPLASH!
Again, he found himself completely submerged
and drowning.
After a minute, he did emerge from the puddle,
but not in one piece.
Knowledgeable of this incident,
the Foundation set about expunging any traces
of the monster's description from the world,
physical and digital.
The description had low distribution according
to the results of Foundation web crawlers,
but this hardly stopped the Foundation's endeavor.
With forum posts deleted, individuals located
and amnesticized, and catalogs trawled to
ensure the description did not proliferate,
the Foundation engaged in what it does best:
Questionably ethical experiments.
First, they had an anonymous D-Class, uninformed
of the creature's effect, read the description
of the beast.
While the pamphlet they gave him confused
him somewhat, he didn't feel particularly
frightened by the entity, and he confusedly
put on the diving suit the Foundation testers
provided him.
As they connected him to a cable and told
him to enter a bathtub, the D-Class did as
they instructed him.
The D-Class expressed initial confusion at
the tub's depth, remarking that it "looked
so tiny from the outside''.
As the D-Class continued to descend, he analyzed
his surroundings, realizing the nautical reality
that enveloped him.
He asked how an ocean got stuffed into a bathtub,
but the test organizer had no room for miscellaneous
talk.
He continued to descend until he hit the sandy
bottom, seaweed covering the ocean floor.
The D-Class looked around.
Tropical fish swam in schools, coral covered
the seabed, and to his right dropped an immense
cliff, a sheer edge.
The test organizer advised the D-Class to
approach the cliff, and he begrudgingly complied.
As he struggled in his diving suit, he fell
back and screamed.
SCP-1128 The aquatic horror
swam distantly, gracefully even, and paid
no attention to the D-Class so fixated upon
it.
He realized that the creature matched the
one he read on the pamphlet, and almost complained
about this when he saw a blue whale swimming
alongside SCP-1128.
Compared to the monster, the whale looked
like a guppy.
The whale glided in front of SCP-1128's jaws.
The monster remained tranquil, stared at its
prey, and bit the whale in two with one chomp.
Its teeth glistened in the water.
The test operator requested the D-Class to
pull back, and as the cable began to draw
him toward where he came, the D-Class stared
at the creature, swallowing the chunks of
whale whole.
The D-Class' eyes remained fixated on the
creature, partly in fright, partly in awe.
He wondered how ocean trawlers hadn't discovered
such a giant beast yet, with the world effectively
under one hundred percent surveillance - something
the D-Class knew far too well as a convict.
Yet, the D-Class recognized - and if not comprehended
- partially understood the ocean's vastness
and mystery.
The dark depths reveal no inkling as to their
contents, and a creature like the giant squid
or the coelacanth
can remain in hiding for centuries, if not
millennia.
It held him in wondrous thought to consider
the vastness of the depths.
When SCP-1128 stopped and stared at the D-Class,
this feeling of wonder was quickly replaced
with fear.
As the creature approached, the D-Class pleaded
with the test operators for help, as the test
operators accelerated the rate of the cable
returning.
The D-Class took short, shallow breaths, filling
his body with dangerous nitrogen as he ascended,
further impairing his judgment.
He had devolved to gibberish and screaming
when, face-to-face, the monster consumed its
prey.
The cable went slack, and the test operator
pulled up only a broken wire, snapped, the
water turning a cloudy red.
The test operator knew that unprotected D-Class
had no chance at survival against the monster,
but he could potentially arm and shield them.
He had another, similarly ignorant D-Class
once again dress in a Scuba suit and enter
the tub.
However, the test operator placed the D-Class
within a shark cage, ala the movie Jaws, and
lowered the cage in with another cable and
winch system.
While unsure how this would fare with SCP-1128,
the test operator remained hopeful that the
D-Class could survive and recount his story.
Unfortunately, as the cage lowered into the
tub, the test operator received no response
from the D-Class until the line spontaneously
tightened, snapped, and loosened.
Hoping to find the D-Class' remains, the test
operator only found shredded pieces of metal,
torn and twisted like taffy.
The test operator decided that he could utilize
the Foundation's arsenal to his advantage,
and use an anomalously toughened shark cage
in his testing, perhaps using an anomaly like
the clockwork machine SCP-914.
He gained approval from his higher-ups to
undergo this procedure, and after some testing,
beheld a shining, strong-as-Titanium shark
cage, which he placed another D-Class within.
Hoping for a success with the monster, however,
proved unsatisfactory, as the same thing happened
as the previous test, only without any sort
of metallic remains.
While bitter that the monster had won again,
he wondered where the cage had landed.
Meanwhile, Foundation forces labored tirelessly
to find SCP-1128's location, hoping to avoid
any civilian contact with the creature.
Luckily, a GPS signal established itself upon
the most recent D-Class' test, with the tracking
device on the D-Class signifying the monster's
general location.
The Foundation has redacted the location of
the monster, perhaps in a vain attempt to
hide a very near threat from potential readers.
The Foundation set up a team of only the most
talented boaters in its forces, Mobile Containment
Force Kappa-12, Sea Devils.
Upon arriving at the location, the Sea Devils
discovered the previously enhanced shark cage,
completely undamaged.
However, closer inspection revealed traces
of human DNA on the bars, though the Foundation
could not confirm whether the DNA belonged
to the previously-sent D-Class.
The test operator, while glad his shark cage
survived the monster's attack, still found
himself dissatisfied with the overall results
of the test.
He knew he needed to quell this creature's
impact before a large population viewed it
or knew of it, but the horrible beast had
evaded all attempts at peaceful interaction.
Perhaps with a madness not unlike Captain
Ahab, yearning for the death of his white
whale, the test operator armed a D-Class with
a specialized weapon, designed to deal with
aquatic threats promptly.
This weapon, potentially another of the Foundation's
precious arsenal, could potentially harm if
not kill the creature.
While he knew the Foundation's mission statement
forbade unnecessary destruction, the test
operator felt it may turn necessary if matters
turn any worse.
Thus, he sent his armed D-Class through the
tub once more, ready to engage the beast in
combat.
The attempt, as one may expect, didn't last
long.
The D-Class, upon spotting the creature, aimed
his weapon at the monster and attacked it,
but rather than drive the creature away, it
only turned intently upon the D-Class, as
if desiring a fight.
The D-Class barely managed to scrape SCP-1128
before the creature devoured the D-Class,
leaving the test operator once again empty-handed.
Defeated, and without any more resources to
deal with the beast, the test operator ceased
his attempts at besting the creature and followed
the Foundation's more cautious approach, expunging
any publicly-found descriptions of SCP-1128
as needed and diverting any vessels away from
the anomaly's exclusion zone, as maintained
by the Sea Devils.
While the creature had proven treacherous
in unexpected situations prior, engulfing
the man who first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle, researchers could hardly
expect what would transpire.
A D-Class, afflicted with the monster's effect
and observed for testing, avoided all bodies
of water as required.
Eventually, however, the D-Class needed to
interact with some kind of water: drinking
water.
In a choice between a little water exposure
or certain death, the D-Class felt inclined
to choose the former.
He filled his cup with water and, for fun,
placed his finger into the cup, dropping it
into the water.
SCP-1128, unseen from the outside, violently
pulled the D-Class through the cup into its
watery domain.
The D-Class had not a chance to scream.
This alarmed containment staff, now cognizant
that even the tiniest specs of water could
transport an afflicted person into SCP-1128's
ocean territory.
This proved particularly strenuous when a
new report of a potential SCP-1128 manifestation
arose.
An old woman, isolated with her cats and knitting
supplies, found an article online with a description
of the monster.
Frightened and disgusted by what she had read,
she closed the article and continued on with
her monotonous life.
Such a life would take a turn for the worse,
however, when she too developed that all-encompassing
water-based fear.
Her apartment overlooked an outdoor pool,
and one day, looking outside, she swore she
could see that same dark silhouette as the
man did, lurking in the water among kids and
parents playing.
She swiftly closed the window curtains and
taped the seams shut, allowing no light to
peek through.
Eventually, this paranoia affected her hygiene,
neglecting showers and baths for fear of the
creature's wrath.
She swore she could see the silhouette in
any individual droplet of water.
Her skin began to flake as she avoided water
as much as humanly possible, cracks developing
on her arms, legs, and face, inflaming into
rashes and itches.
Her scratching further increased the flaking.
She even eliminated water from her diet, sealing
the faucets with duct tape and consuming exclusively
orange juice.
She threw out her cats' water bowls, dehydrating
them.
They pleaded with her as she continued to
devolve, avoiding any contact with the outside
world even as it attempted to contact her.
Eventually, a concerned neighbor contacted
the local police concerning the situation,
and the case caught the Foundation's radar,
recognizing the symptoms of a potential SCP-1128
infection.
A mobile task force disguised themselves as
civilians to enter the apartment building
and potentially interfere with the woman's
condition.
They entered the complex, climbing up the
stairs with barraging equipment for forced
entry, as would prove necessary to use to
enter the woman's apartment.
She had nailed the door shut with wood and
sealed the cracks along the sides with plaster,
in an attempt to keep out any water vapor.
She had, similarly, blocked the window with
wood planks.
A horrid miasma of dead skin and citrus filled
the apartment, the old woman soaking it in,
ever avoiding the dreaded monster.
The Foundation task force attempted peaceful
entry, knocking on the door and asking if
anyone lived in the apartment.
The woman couldn't speak if she wanted to;
her throat had dried to near silence save
a croak.
Suddenly, the task force and the woman heard
a rumbling noise outside.
Thunder.
Rain.
The woman panicked, and yelped "Don't come
in here!"
in a froggy voice.
The task force eventually decided they needed
to use their equipment, and entered via barrage.
The door collapsed in as an immensely dense
air clogged the task force's sight, blinding
and choking them.
The woman shrieked, and backed against the
window inadvertently.
The task force insisted they were here to
help the woman, but she simply heaved heavily,
saying something unintelligible in that dry,
cracking voice.
The rain began pounding on the window, patter-patter-patter,
as the task force attempted to gain a hold
on the woman.
She resisted their movements, moving around
the room while the task force intentionally
avoided violent confrontation.
The rain grew in intensity as the woman continued
running around her apartment, tripping over
her starved cats.
Eventually, she fell back onto the window,
at which the boards blocking it fell onto
the floor, exposing the pouring rain fully.
She screamed, as she saw the silhouette of
the monster staring at her in every individual
rain drop.
One drop landed on her skin, and she violently
vanished, pulled into a miniscule spec of
water.
The task force collapsed from exhaustion,
perhaps dreading their inevitable amnestic
treatment following exposure with an SCP-1128
afflictee.
Yet, they couldn't help but wonder what the
old woman saw in a single spec of water that
could cause that degree of fear and paranoia.
The kind of fear only caused by entire oceans,
condensed into a single droplet.
Besides the monster, what else did she see
in those multitude of droplets?
The fish that populated the sea, the whale
carcasses left behind by SCP-1128, the Sea
Devils viewed from below, drifting on the
water, unsuspecting?
Just as one may view a grain of sand and see
the Sahara, she too saw that rain drop and
viewed an ocean entire, along with whatever
malevolent creatures inhabit it.
One may have more sympathy for the child,
reluctant to jump into the pool water, knowing
not necessarily that something inhabits that
body of water, but that the body belongs to
a cycle much larger than itself, larger than
any sea or ocean, and the only thing that
can traverse that cycle is a monster.
A creature like SCP-1128.
The task force went back to their local site
to report what happened during the incident.
Like so many incidents the Foundation deals
with, the sum total of those that risk their
lives for the greater good is a couple memory-erasing
syringes and another update to documentation.
A description of SCP-1128 remains in a stuffy
locker, lurking in wait among other horrifying
stories in the SCP database's sea of terror.
Just like that test operator that attempted
to best the monster, could the Foundation's
attempts ever surmount the possibility of
another person being afflicted?
Could they conquer the sea?
In a member of that task force's dreams, they
perceive a dark blue ocean, and the distant
black shadow that resides within.
And from this ocean they can view the bath
tubs, sinks, pools, puddles, cups of water,
and rain droplets of the world, seen from
below.
Although they know not what SCP-1128 looks
like, they too experience the fear it summons
among those that do, the paranoia, the fear.
Although it may not manifest directly in people's
lives, it can always be observed, stalking,
waiting.
Lurking under a murky surface.
Watching with hidden eyes.
Now go check out “SCP-3000 - Anantashesha”
and “SCP-057-IT - Under the Sea” for more
anomalous entities that lurk in the deep and
dark depths of the Sea!